>>> CONGRESSWOMAN MARJORIE
TAYLOR GREENE HAS LANDED A PAIR
OF POWERFUL COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS, HOMELAND SECURITY
AND OVERSIGHT.
THIS IS THE SAME WOMAN WHO
PUSHED 9/11 CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND SHE'S NOW ON THE HOMELAND
SECURITY COMMITTEE.
>> THE SO-CALLED PLANE THAT
CRASHED INTO THE PENTAGON, ODD
THERE'S NEVER ANY EVIDENCE SHOWN
OF A PLANE.
THERE'S AN ISLAMIC INVESTIGATION
INTO OUR GOVERNMENT OFFICES.
HOW DO YOU GET AVID GUN OWNERS
TO GIVE UP THEIR GUNS?
MAYBE YOU ESTABLISH THAT BY
PERFORMING A MASS SHOOTING INTO
A CROWD.
YOU MAKE THEM SCARED AND CHANGE
THEIR MIND SIGHT.
KENNEDY KILLED IN A PLANE CRASH,
THAT'S ANOTHER ONE OF THOSE
CLINTON MURDERS.
ACCORDING TO HIM, MANY IN OUR
GOVERNMENT ARE ACTIVELY
WORSHIPPING SATAN.
Q IS SAYING THAT THEY
PARTICIPATE IN PEDOPHILIA AND
SPIRIT COOKING.
WE SAW AN EMAIL OUT OF WIKILEAKS
EMAILS WHERE CHERYL MOLS SAID
SHE WAS GOING TO SACRIFICE A
CHICKEN IN HER BACKYARD.
SAUDI ARABIA HE SAYS ARE THE
PUPPET MASTERS THAT FUND THIS
GLOBAL EVIL.
>> DON'T FORGET ABOUT JEWISH
SPACE LASERS.
A SEAT ON THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE WILL PUT HER IN A
POSITION TO INVESTIGATE
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IT'S A LOT OF POWER FOR SOMEONE
STRIPPED OF HER COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS.
>> NOT JUST MARJORIE TAYLOR
GREENE, ANOTHER REPUBLICAN HAS
BEEN PLACED ON COMMITTEES.
NEWLY ELECTED CONGRESSMAN GEORGE
SANTOS IS ON TWO DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES DESPITE PRESSURE
GROWING FOR HIM TO RESIGN
BECAUSE OF THE FABRICATIONS OF
HIS BACKGROUND.
ONE OF THE COMMITTEES IS THE
COMMITTEE ON SMALL BUSINESS.
THE OTHER THAT HE'S GOING TO BE
SITTING ON IS SCIENCE, SPACE AND
TECHNOLOGY.
SOME OF SANTOS' COLLEAGUES ARE
DEFENDING THE DECISION.
>> THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT HIS
PAST.
WHY GIVE HIM COMMITTEE
ASSIGNMENTS?
>> AGAIN, HE HASN'T COMMITTED A
CRIME.
HE HASN'T BEEN INDICTED ON
ANYTHING.
IN THIS COUNTRY YOU'RE INNOCENT
UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY.
WE'RE GOING TO TREAT HIM LIKE
ANY OTHER MEMBER AND KEEP AN EYE
ON
ON HIM.
>> I WANT TO BRING IN THE FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF OF HOMELAND
SECURITY DURING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
NEITHER OF THESE ARE REALLY PLUM
ASSIGNMENTS, BUT THE FACT HE GOT
TWO COMMITTEES SEEM TO BE AN
OBVIOUS INDICATION OF HOW
REPUBLICANS ARE DEALING WITH
GEORGE SANTOS.
>> IT SAYS A LOT ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO TRY TO DO.
MORE SIGNIFICANTLY IS WHERE THEY
DIDN'T PUT GEORGE SANTOS.
MY SOURCES ON CAPITOL HILL TELL
ME THEY HAD ORIGINALLY
CONSIDERED HIM FOR SEVERAL
NATIONAL SECURITY COMMITTEES,
BUT DECIDED AGAINST IT BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO TRUST GEORGE
SANTOS WITH CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION.
SO THAT TELLS YOU TWO THINGS.
IT TELLS YOU THAT THEY VIEW
SOMETHING LIKE THE SMALL
BUSINESS COMMITTEE LIKE A THROW
AWAY COMMITTEE AND, TWO, THEY DO
DRAW A LINE ON WHICH MEMBERS
THEY DO AND DON'T TRUST WITH
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
GIVEN ALL THE ALLEGATIONS, THEY
PUT GEORGE SANTOS IN, QUOTE,
SAFER COMMITTEES.
>> I WONDER, MILES, IF THEY'RE
NOT TELLING HIM EVERYTHING.
I IMAGINE HE THINKS HE'S ALL
GOOD.
ARE THEY MEETING BEHIND CLOSED
DOORS AND SAYING WE CAN'T TRUST
THIS GUY?
>> I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
RIGHT.
THEY'RE PROBABLY TRYING TO PUT
GEORGE SANTOS IN THE PLACE THAT
THEY THINK HE CAN DO THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF DAMAGE I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY TO THE COUNTRY.
THEY'RE PROBABLY PUTTING HIM
SOMEWHERE HE CAN DO THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF DAMAGE TO THE PARTY,
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY, UNTIL
THEY'RE TOLD BY THE ETHICS
COMMITTEE WHERE THEY STAND.
KEVIN McCARTHY AND OTHERS KEEP
TRYING TO BUY THEMSELVES TIME
WHEN IT COMES TO GEORGE SANTOS
BY SAYING THEY'LL GO THROUGH
NORMAL PROCESSES.
IN OTHER WORDS THE ETHICS
COMMITTEE WILL LOOK INTO IT.
>> THE ETHICS COMMITTEE MOVES
FAMOUSLY VERY QUICKLY.
I'M KIDDING.
MILES, WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TORE
MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE BEING
PLACED ON THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE?
>> IF I WAS STILL CHIEF OF STAFF
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY I WOULD TELL THEM
YOU'RE NOT TO BRIEF HER WITHOUT
MY AUTHORIZATION.
I DON'T THINK DHS, I DON'T THINK
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
SHOULD TRUST THIS MEMBER OF
CONGRESS.
THAT'S NOT SPECK LA TV.
IT'S BASED ON WHAT SHE'S SAID IN
THE PAST.
SHE'S ON THE COMMITTEE THAT'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR PREVENTING ACTS
OF DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
THE JANUARY 6th ATTACK ON THE
U.S. CAPITOL WAS THE LARGEST
DOMESTIC TERRORIST ATTACK AND
WHAT DID MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE
SAY ABOUT THAT ATTACK?
IF SHE WAS IN CHARGE, WE WOULD
HAVE WON.
THAT'S ALARMING.
THE COMMITTEE OVERSEES ELECTION
SECURITY.
SHE TRIED TO OVERTURN AN
ELECTION.
IT RECEIVES VERY SENSITIVE
INTELLIGENCE.
IN THE PAST SHE'S ACCUSED THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY OF
RUNNING DEEP STATE OPERATIONS
AGAINST AMERICANS.
YOU WORRY WHAT SHE'LL DO WITH
THE INFORMATION SHE GETS ON THAT
COMMITTEE.
DONALD TRUMP IS ALWAYS A PHONE
CALL AWAY.
SHE'S IN REGULAR TOUCH WITH HIM
AS WE'VE SEEN FROM PICTURES ON
THE HOUSE FLOOR DURING KEVIN
McCARTHY'S SPEAKERSHIP BATTLE.
>> REPUBLICANS HAVE PLACED SIX
PEOPLE WHO QUESTION THE RESULTS
OF THE 2020 ELECTION ON HOMELAND
SECURITY, SEVEN MORE ON THE
ELECTION COMMITTEE.
MILES, APPRECIATE IT.
>> JEFF ZELENY JOINS US NOW
ALONG WITH ABBY PHILLIP.
IN YOUR PIECE AND COMMENTS SHE
MADE 9/11 QUESTIONING THE ATTACK
ON THE PENTAGON, NOW SHE'LL HAVE
A SEAT ON THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE WHICH WAS FOUNDED IN
REACTION TO 9/11.
WHAT DO WE EXPECT FOR HER ON
THAT COMMITTEE?
>> SHE IS FIRST AND FOREMOST
FOCUSED ON THE BORDER, OF
COURSE, THAT'S WHAT MANY HOUSE
REPUBLICANS ARE FOCUSED ON
PARTICULARLY THE POLICIES OF THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION AND OF THE
DHS SECRETARY ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS
SO LOOK FOR AN INVESTIGATION
THAT COULD POTENTIALLY LEAD TO
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS.
WE WILL SEE HOW THAT PLAYS OUT
BUT THIS IS REALLY A TEST FOR
HER BECAUSE JUST TODAY SHE WAS
PUT BACK ON THESE COMMITTEES.
SHE'S ESSENTIALLY BEEN -- HAD A
LOT OF FREE TIME ON HER HAND THE
LAST COUPLE OF YEARS BECAUSE SHE
HASN'T SERVED ON ANY COMMITTEES
BUT SHE WILL BE SERVING ON THE
HOMELAND SECURITY COMMITTEE AND
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE SO WE'LL SEE
HOW THEE CONDUCTS HERSELF.
SHE WILL BE A MEMBER BUT THE
BORDER SEEMS AT LEAST FOR NOW
HER FOCUS.
>> ABBY, SHE SUPPORTED KEVIN
McCARTHY THROUGHOUT HIS BID.
GREENE SHOWING UNWAVERING
DEDICATION.
WHERE DOES THIS PLACE HER IN THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY?
>> SHE SAID SEVERAL MONTHS AGO
IF REPUBLICANS TOOK OVER THE
HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES WHICH
THEY DID, THAT SHE WOULD BE ONE
OF THE MOST POWERFUL MEMBERS OF
THE HOUSE AND I THINK THAT SHE
PROBABLY LIKE A LOT OF OTHER
MEMBERS GIVEN OUT THEIR MAUL
MAJORITY IS IN A REAL POSITION
OF POWER BECAUSE I THINK THAT
SHE LEAPT KEVIN McCARTHY QUITE A
LOT OF CREDIBILITY AND THAT
RELATIONSHIP IF IT IS
TRANSACTIONAL IT IS IN BOTH
DIRECTIONS.
HE NEEDS HER AS MUCH AS SHE
NEEDS HIM FOR AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE ON COMMITTEES TO HAVE SOME
KIND OF REAL POWER.
SO I THINK THAT SHE'S
STRATEGICALLY HAS QUITE A LOT OF
POWER RIGHT NOW.
THE QUESTION IS, IS SHE GOING TO
USE IT IN A WAY THAT THAT IS
GOOD FOR HER OR GOOD FOR THE
REPUBLICAN MA SCOMBROERT.
I THINK THOSE ARE NOT
NECESSARILY THE SAME THING AND
WE'LL SEE WHETHER THIS STRATEGIC
MATURITY THAT JEFF IS TALKING
ABOUT HOLDS ONCE THERE'S A LOT
OF PRESSURE ON KEVIN McCARTHY IN
THE COMING MONTHS FROM THE RIGHT
FLANK OF WHICH SHE'S STILL A
PART.